have you ever googled yourself no my
mother told me not to do that right I'm
Marvin Freeman Michael Caine Alan Arkin
we're here to play this game never have
I ever never have I ever
they say that we're going to have fun I
doubt that very seriously but here we go
okay here we go
and everybody calls me a curmudgeon
calling a comedian who's it look have
you ever shoplift
no I take the fifth have you ever wished
you had a different voice not I know
have you ever been confused for another
actor I was in a airport in Dallas and
this guy comes over to mem slap down the
scene he says you're trying to be
incognito but I recognized you so oh
yeah and say yeah you know samuel
l.jackson if you can't the heart I said
I'm not Sam Jackson he said you're lying
but it's okay I was standing in the
airport two guys recognized me and one
approached me and he said Robert Redford
he said you you're my favorite actor and
so I said I'm not Robert Redford but I
felt we are Robert Redford Lisa I was
Robert Redford and the other bloke came
up to Woody Allen have you ever refused
to do a stunt you bet
I had yes there was a scene in the
in-laws when they wanted me and Peter
Falk to be coming out of it he look up
run us on a swing then they had us about
300 feet up and they had a schedule for
halfway through the movie I said okay
and then they kept putting it back and
back into the schedule uncle was the
last shot it was the last shot of the
movie so angry okay that is the thing
never do a stunt
on the last day that means it's
dangerous any stunt you do do on the
first day have you ever asked for a body
double for a nude scene see me yeah yeah
III have yes but I've got to good I mean
I'm so proud of my body that I threw it
off at everyone
new teen because it is a nude scene in
the picture I wouldn't do it as an actor
you're controlling what the audience
does listens to and where they look once
you're in the nude you are no longer in
control have you ever been starstruck
you've been stars oh oh yeah yeah yeah I
met Gregory Peck once I mean he's is
always been one of my top favorites
Shirley MacLaine brought me to Hollywood
and I've never been to Hollywood so I
was sitting there lobby in the Beverly
Hills hotel looking for film stars see
if I got any film stars and one day John
Wayne came in and he looked round and he
saw me and he said you're gonna be a big
star kid I said look fake a mr. Wayne is
very kindly so but let me give you a
piece of advice he said talk low talk
slow and don't say too much and never
wear suede shoes I said never wear suede
shoes I said why not
he said because as I said gonna be a big
star kid you're gonna be in the toilet
taking a pee the guy's gonna turn to say
Michael Caine is you're gonna pee all
over your shoes have you ever done an
impression of one of your co-stars Ben
Affleck started doing me a terrible
version of me terrible but it wouldn't
stop he did it he started doing
I heard him do about 30 times II was
doing a night talk shows we [ __ ] I leave
the Academy Awards on the red carpet I
started doing hi I'm I'm Ben Affleck
tonight I'm playing Batman and he grabs
grabs my head he's please don't do that
so [ __ ] that stopped Oh have you ever
had a job you loved as much as acting
I'd loved it so much I'd do it for
nothing but oh I don't tell producers
that I worked for years with no money
just got to get on stage the first 30
years of my life 40 years of the Act it
was actor die but then I discovered
directing and writing and teaching and I
found a lot of joy in all of those I
never wanted to direct cuz I like to go
home early
[Music]